[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades the debate around controller
players using claw grip has raged on
since competitive gaming first arrived
the strange thing is it seems to bring
out the worst in people
we take aside and force it upon other
people so I'm going to try and explain
my approach my experiences as a first
generation player who once played claw
I'll also show you a few exercises to
help condition your hands if you decide
to dedicate yourself to claw and I'll
even show you some of the gross things
my hands do now thanks to amongst other
things 20 years of gaming thus the only
place to start is by showcasing why
players use claw grip it's ultra simple
it's about getting an advantage over
other players basically by moving your
index finger across the face buttons and
using your middle finger to use the
shoulder buttons it suddenly becomes
possible to do anything on a controller
jumping and aiming is easy crouching
without moving your thumb is instinctive
ultimately this is how a player must
play to stay competitive and in
keyboard/mouse lobbies it's almost
imperative the only alternative is
spending money on a modded controller
like a scuff or switching to mouse and
keyboard I was reading an article before
putting this together which people
called claw grip the free scuf
controller looking at the game like
fortnight professional controller
players have this same decision to make
play claw like ghost Aiden or buy a scuf
controller like Nick mercs when I
started gaming controllers looked like
this yeah I'm old I am sold
then PlayStation released the analog
controller dubbed the Dual Shock which
added thumbsticks
more than 20 years later this design is
still the norm it's still functionally
the same so I'm going to use my hands as
a case study when games began to utilize
thumb sticks I began to hold the
controller like this I remember it
hurting like hell but over time the pain
went away at the time I told myself it
was simply my hands becoming used to a
new controller setup
I now know 20 years later pain and
discomfort are very different things
and my body was trying to tell me to
stop let's try and visualize this hold
up your controller and have someone take
it away try to hold that pose your hands
are simply not designed to be held in
this way for long periods of time try
that again with claw grip not only do
you look like a dinosaur trying to give
the middle finger it's simply an
uncomfortable position adding extra
pressure to your index finger here is
something you must do if you want to use
claw over your gaming life or gaming
career in fact is for all of us take
regular breaks I know nobody takes that
seriously but it's unbelievably
important to give your hands time to
rest and recuperate
playing six hours without moving is
insane and I still do it now so I
understand how difficult it is to stop
taking breaks is damn hard to do so
here's another telltale sign you have to
rest and have a night off every so often
if you've ever experienced involuntary
movement in your fingers also known as a
twitch when you hold your hand out and
your fingers keep pressing the buttons
without you even knowing if this happens
to you it's time to rethink your gaming
schedule acknowledge the science you may
feel young and invincible but wait 15
years and you'll wish you took care of
your hands sooner have you heard of a
condition called halves
I can't mine but it stands for but it's
basically what labourers suffer from if
they use something like a pneumatic
drill which I believe is called a
jackhammer in the US sorry if that's
wrong it can cause nerve damage making
their hands and arms numb cold and in
some cases unusable I'm not saying this
directly links to holding a controller
but I'm trying to show you that doing
something slightly uncomfortable for
many years can and will lead to issues
coincidentally this is why I turned off
the vibration function in many games so
two years ago I went to the doctors to
talk about arthritis carpal tunnel and
all the other scary things we are told
that could happen to our hands that's
where I learned a plethora of exercises
which would help gamers here's three
exercises my doctor gave me two combat
controller and keep out of mouse issues
these exercises have helped me and are
for all gamers regardless of if you play
claw standard or mouse and keyboard
right bring your thumb into your hand as
far as you can you should feel a pull in
your wrist a lower end of your thumb if
this hurts loosen it up but we do want
to feel a little stretch
next we are going to fan our fingers
from our pinky to our index the doctor
called this piano fingers do this for
about 30 seconds of time I began to do
this in game lobbies whilst waiting for
a game to begin it doesn't need anything
to be done it's a quick stretch and it's
certainly worth it
next is the tennis stretch also used for
arthritis hold your arm out like you're
telling someone to stop take your other
hand and apply pressure for about 30
seconds do the same with your hand
flexing the other direction but remember
to know the difference between a stretch
discomfort and pain only apply a little
pressure due to the way we hold a
controller a mouse or even a mobile
phone it's possible that grip strength
is impacted in other words you won't be
able to open jars when you get older
unless you start taking care of it now
if you take nothing else from this video
take this one
grab a stress ball or something
squishable and simply tighten your grip
repeatedly for 30 seconds even try this
tri grip it fast for three then slow for
two it improves your circulation reminds
your hands to stay strong and best of
all it's a great way to de-stress after
someone kills you in game dam to stream
snipers those three exercises were
beneficial to me so I thought I'd share
them I have so many more receive
straight from the doctors so if you'd
like me to put them in a video give me a
shout
I hear that some countries don't have
free health care so if I can save you a
few dollars rupees or Euros and extend
your gaming lifespan give me a shout so
we've looked at why claw is great for a
competitive edge and we've looked at
conditioning our hands for the good of
our health but what if you don't want to
take the claw chance is the only other
option a modded controller but those
that don't know a modern controller
usually adds paddles to the underside of
the controller to allow buttons to be
pressed by fingers which usually simply
stabilize the controller I recently
reviewed a scuff impact and saw both
benefits and drawbacks I won't go into
detail here but the price was pretty
high for many of us it's simply not
possible to buy a controller in that
price range so I've tried to find
alternative to a scuff with the cheapest
this strike pack which attaches to your
standard controller and adds paddle
functionality it costs about the same as
a triple-a game rather than 200 plus
dollars on a fully kitted scuff
other brands are also moving into the
modded controller territory razor evil
controllers make on a stroke all these
manufacturers should mean the
marketplace of modded controllers drops
in the coming years things should get
cheaper one day regular consumers won't
be forced to risk additional hand
injuries to compete well that's the
dream anyway without a doubt in my mind
I believe a modded controller is the far
safer option to protect your hands
long-term it isn't ideal but the
positioning of your hands stays as
neutral as possible no additional
pressure on your knuckle joints are
incorrect motion of your index finger so
I guess from that I'm on the side of not
playing claw if you're interested in my
story I'll tell it now I recently hit my
30s it's depressing as hell I found a
gray hair last week anyway I started to
have problems with my hands they felt
numb on occasion at worst it felt like
someone else was controlling my fingers
and I hit rock bottom when I lost
feeling in two fingers over Christmas
2018 and I knew I needed to sort it I
saw a specialist and took my controller
to show her the movements to hopefully
find some correlation between the issues
so check this out but don't watch this
if you're eating because it's pretty
gross
we found correlations to many weaknesses
in my hand thanks to gaming using a
mobile phone and using a mouse and
keyboard
especially the mouse and keyboard by the
way because I never had a wrist rest
before this point so I was crushing the
nerves in my wrist without realizing I'm
such an idiot
after giving up claw I began to press
the X button on the ps4 pad with my
right thumb without taking it off the
thumb stick basically hyperextending my
thumb thousands of times an hour if I
try to do that now this happens my thumb
dislocates it's lovely isn't it next 20
years of gripping a controller has
assisted in ligament damage in my
fingers when a controller is removed
from my grasp this happened to my
knuckles down that's gross but without a
doubt the numbness or being unable to
feel my fingers was the scariest thing
to ever happen to me as a gamer the
moment I felt most crushed was when I
was unable to open a bottle of milk I
had zero grip strength and I
felt useless luckily we live in a time
of medical marvel and after a steroid
injection into my wrists which hurt like
health
everything improved and I decided to
learn from that situation and make sure
it doesn't happen again
because the average person can only take
that steroid injection six times before
it causes harm so I don't fancy using up
those extra lives just yet
three months later I still have issues
and expect you for the rest of my life
I've made peace with that but I'm hoping
this will help other people whether you
choose to use claw grip or not I don't
know but it's part of a bigger issue for
gamers please take care of your body
anywhere you can
don't become me regretting your actions
take regular breaks strengthen and
exercise your hands don't let your
wrists bend too much when you're using a
mobile phone force your school or
workplace to invest in wrist rests when
using a keyboard and mouse you only get
one shot at this life no response no
continues something as simple as
spending a little extra money on a
modded controller may extend your gaming
career for years let me know your
thoughts no company has sponsored this
video I'm not adding Amazon links to
make money this was simply my opinion on
the claw debate which is only a tiny
portion of a bigger issue for gamers I
do hope it was useful this video will
likely bomb so if he could help share it
that would be really appreciated I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade I'll see
you next time
[Music]